[Music]
for 20 years now new yorkers have woken
up to this day
to relive to remember
some forced to
others want to
in a church yard just yards from ground
zero the bell of hope rings out
a gift from the city of london to new
york city
five strikes repeated four times the
traditional firefighters salute to the
fallen it was a day just like today
wasn't it
the day just like today the clergy are
here with words of comfort that can only
go so far
a block south from where the towers once
stood is an institution which survived
as the buildings fell o'hara's is now a
focal point for survivors and relatives
each year as the ceremony finishes they
gather here
inside the walls are covered with the
badges of the first responders without
their bravery so many more would have
died
my bravery was nothing compared to the
343 guys that walked into a building
that day knowing they were going to die
and really that's what happened they
knew they were going to die that day
richie lost five of his close friends
he went in there to go you know help
them as firefighters get as many people
out as he could
sean burch lost his uncle how are you
feeling today 20 years on i mean it's
definitely emotional you know it never
every year is tough but you know 20
years it seems like it was yesterday you
know it's really tough you know every
year it's like you're really living
reliving it over and over again so you
know it's very tough but it's always
important to remember and never forget
they didn't lose their lives for no
reason so i think it's very important to
come celebrate every year
[Music]
in other corners of manhattan we found
more small gatherings reflecting the
queen elizabeth memorial garden was the
focus for the british and commonwealth
losses 67 british people died 20 years
ago
representing queen and government the
ambassador it's a good moment to come
together but i think also people draw a
lot of strength from the resilience that
new york city
and its people showed immediately after
9 11
in rebuilding and i think if i had to
pick one thing to take away from today
it would be that
in the end it comes down to moments like
this sharing memories remembering never
forgetting but understanding why
believing that america is truly safer
now that something like this could never
happen again well that's harder
in this city which never sleeps there is
resilience
but always grief
mark stone sky news in new york